nancy pelosi admitting she was playing
politics while millions of americans are
out of work and businesses across the
country
are on the brink of collapse after
months of stalling negotiations pelosi
finally ready to accept a smaller
coronavirus bill
all because joe biden is headed for the
white house
what is shifted now when they're on
board with this piece that's come out of
the sun
perhaps you missed what i said earlier
joe biden committed
to ending and crushing the virus what
was then before was not
more of this this is has simplicity
it's what we've had in our bills it's
for a shorter period of time
but that's okay now because we have a
new president
dana did she just admit that she held up
trillions of stimulus for
hard-working suffering americans for
politics
sounds like it to me and it's so
upsetting
you know it's going to take a at least
like four weeks
from when they pass a coveted relief
bill for the treasury to get payments
out to people
so you're talking about needless
suffering over the holidays
by p for people that are
in this position through no fault of
their own and their government has
completely let them down
and what she's not only just admitting
that she held it up
for joe biden but if i was a moderate
democrat that just lost my seat
to all of these republicans that crushed
them yeah i would be so mad because
if you remember jesse one of the things
i kept saying is the moderate democrats
are saying we need this relief bill we
need it
to not just campaign on but our
constituents need it
she couldn't deliver it so she was
willing to sacrifice
all of those house seats so that now
they have a very slim majority in the
house and the republicans will likely
take over in 2022 all because
she wanted to help joe biden win the
white house i mean
it's quite stunning and i'm surprised
that there so many democrats are
comfortable with her continuing to be
speaker after this
yet they call her greg a masterful
politician over and over again
yeah i thought that was gelato on her
hands but it looks like it's blood
remember trump shut the economy down
swiftly without any hesitation people
forget about this
knowing that it could destroy his legacy
he did help create the
probably historically one of the
greatest economies ever but he was
willing to risk it
rather than let people die if pelosi was
president
up for re-election do you think she
would have done that
hell no she would have like let them eat
gelato hey i want to read this thing i
got from facebook this is a great idea
from a guy named chip weber for the
restaurants
restaurants should file an llc it's
quick and easy
paperwork for a production company have
some cameras
like a phone on tripods and film a
documentary about the restaurant
business
or a pilot reality show in a restaurant
and then have the public sign releases
and then you could have your outdoor
dining very smart
chip there you go just call it a photo
shoot
some of the best ideas come from
facebook um
degan what do you think about nancy
pelosi one of the reasons she gets away
with stuff like this
right one of the reason nancy you know
gets away with things like this is
because there's no pressure
from the media if a republican did this
and sometimes i wish we had
a republican politician as cold-hearted
and as calculating
as nancy pelosi but alas i can only
dream well she sacrificed her
her own members of the democratic party
um
just so she wouldn't give president
trump a win she's standing atop
the suffering and misery of not just all
the american people but her constituents
so she's plumbing new
depths of loathsomeness and all of this
she actually said no
to a 1.9 trillion dollar offer from the
white house so what she's accepting now
is one trillion dollars less than that
and all along it was about hundreds of
billions of dollars in unspent money
from the rescue in the spring that all
she had to do was step
up and reallocate she didn't do that
because she was trying to hand
trump a loss i said this months ago
that nothing was better than something
for nancy pelosi
i have a lot of ideas about where she
can stick that
finger of hers but i will stifle
all right herald does she pay a price
ever for any of these tactics
she's already paid the price jesse in
terms of the uh
the democrats losing house seats but i
mean from russia russia to the
fake impeachment to visit me in
chinatown
uh you know she turned down as dagon
says 1.8 trillion
she's taking less than half of what
mnuchin the treasury secretary was
offering her
because she's dopey and prideful and
counterproductive
and i know my wife erica is going to get
mad at me for saying that but she's a
lousy politician
she's a she's a dictator within that
party
but uh you know people are seeing
through it now there's no stimulus
checks
involved in the 908 billion no one's
going to get 1200
no one's going to get the 500 per kid
these stimulus checks are going to do
businesses might be healthy angela with
the restaurant
but uh this is this is this is
malfeasance
on an epic scale
all right geraldo will try to go for the
rest of the show without his wife being
mad at him now